Que nadie tenga ninguna duda
de que todas aquellas personas que hoy Han
confiado en el partido socialista de Euskadi,
Euskadi, que es guerra,
de que su voto
VA a servir
para lo que hemos dicho durante toda la campaña.
VA a servir para mejorar
la vida de los vascos y de las vacas,
para proteger y reforzar nuestros servicios públicos,
para garantizar las políticas progresistas en Euskadi,
para garantizar la pluralidad y, en definitiva,
para hacer la política que quiere
1 inmensa mayoría en este país.
Durante
durante los últimos días hemos dicho
que hemos ganado la campaña electoral
y no cabe duda
de que ese acierto
se ha trasladado a 1 resultado que nos confirma
que confirma nuestra apuesta por la política de verdad.
Pese a los intentos de polarizar esta campaña,
pese a la desidia de algunos
con el relajo de la semana Santa
o con las merecidas fiestas a causa de la gabarra,
hemos sabido trasladar
la certeza de que el voto al partido socialista
es necesario, es útil,
es imprescindible para decidir nuestro futuro.
Quiero agradecer este resultado
a mi, a mi comisión ejecutiva,
a los miembros del comité Nacional de mi partido,
a todos los miembros de todos los órganos de dirección
del partido socialista
de Euskadi, Euskadi, coesquerra
y también a nuestros compañeros
del partido socialista obrero español,
con Pedro Sánchez a la cabeza,
que nos Han ayudado, que nos Han aupado
y por tanto este triunfo,
este Gran resultado
también es suyo